hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to show you something that i've
never seen before i'm talking here about
what is happening on the option market
for sprt i'm also going to talk about
bbig we're going to go through the
charts and through the synthetic short
interest let's get into it
[Music]
yes so let's start quickly with uh the
chart so sprt not an easy one
so basically we had here this a huge cap
and handle that we had here the breakout
when this breakout occurred i told you
guys on my discord that this would
probably go much higher which happened
then let's go on the first time frame we
had this correction here and i have to
say that in our live trading portfolios
we took a trade here and
we were playing basically this fifth
wave so let's see if this fifth wave is
going to come for now i i'm not sure
so one two three then you measure this
and usually false waves they go to the
uh you know so 38.2 that this is the
what the book is saying percentage
retracement of way three in reality it's
50 or 61.8 so we tried to buy these
levels and we got stopped as usual guys
by us here a small fake out just below
the support level this is training it
happens so we are personally out of this
trade we took a small loss which is
totally fine but i have to say
that this looks bullish again
because now so yes this correction was a
bit too deep to me you know for first
wave but we are here in a very different
situation from uh what is usually
happening because we have this i'm going
to show you guys this very soon
impressive synthetic short interest the
option market is just crazy and here
technically first we have this breakout
all right so here's small takeout below
21.5
uh then we trade above we got yesterday
the breakout on the first time frame
above this trendline and then we moved
higher so probably we're gonna have here
one small opportunity today at the open
to set up a trade so i'm not sure we're
gonna do something but i have a cool
idea that we can do using options so
let's have a look guys at the synthetic
short interest so sprt so as usual guys
you know this spreadsheet i'm retrieving
all the open interest from the uh call
options on equal options as i know that
retail is long cold so i know that
market makers have the opposite position
and this helps me to guess what the
dynamics are going to be so basically
i'm checking if there is gamma or not
and if there are a lot of shots so here
first information we have 60 of
synthetic shock interest okay the market
cap is smaller 500 million us dollars
the maximum synthetic shot is 112
all right so this is the biggest i've
ever seen as far as i'm concerned so
let's see where this is coming from it's
coming from september mostly so you have
here
the uh 30 strike that is huge
you know basically everything is coming
from september and you have here this 85
strike that is absolutely massive and
that is growing so you can see it here
guys so here we have this strike that is
growing so all of this is in september
so this momentum will keep only until
september unless those collapsions are
rolled now look at this guys look at the
volatility of september we have a
volatility of
400 something all right 520 percent of
the 42 strike i mean you know so
everybody's buying around the 40 area
you can see the volatility here is
higher than is decreasing alright so the
highest ball is between 40 and 50. so
don't go for this strikes unless i'm
gonna show you how to take advantage of
the situation but buying this is just
giving free money to market makers
because the volatility they use for
pricing is i've never seen something
above that i mean at this levels amc for
example was 200 you know which was
already insane here we are close to 500
so let me show you how to take advantage
of this i posted this in the option
options alerts on my discord so you can
have a look i'm not sure we're gonna put
this strategy uh in our books uh because
i'm afraid the spreads are gonna be high
so basically uh let me show you what i
do here so we start from scratch uh we
want to buy some codes right so let's go
for a 40 strike call we buy one
then we see the volatility is for 488
percent guys i mean
you know 488
imagine this volatility was not at 488
but was at the realized volatility all
right this is the 60 day if i take the
10 day
is that
370 all right so let's say the
volatility is at 370 the price goes from
275 so 275 us dollars for one call
option
if i put this volatility as it should be
fair
the price goes to 1.4 okay so you
basically pay twice the price that it
should be if you only buy this coil
option so you can go for it but
just be aware that uh half of the of
your money is used for market makers uh
to protect themselves against a strong
move up so this is not a fair price to
me so what i would do here i would still
go for this 40 strike because it looks
good right but i would cap cap the
performance above 60
first thing so i reduce the cost of my
premium and i say volatility that is
slightly lower but still extremely high
so now it cost me only 170 us dollars
and i'm gonna have the same performance
until 16 which is fine for me i mean you
know if this goes to 60 it's still a
nice performance if you want to get the
full upside then of course you should
not sell this uh higher strike call and
it's still expensive to me 170 us
dollars for a 175 percent strike with
maturity one week roughly i am here in
september it is too much so i want to
reduce that so what we can do here is to
sell a 50 put strike because you're
gonna
increase your position your exposure the
delta the total delta is now 35 so
basically if you buy one option it's the
same as having 35 shares in terms of
exposure at this spot but of course it's
moving and now we reduce the cost to
zero and we took advantage of this very
high volt so we get in a trade where the
volatility is insane
but we actually don't buy this
volatility here our vga position is
close to zero as you can see when the
premium is close to zero the volatility
exposure is usually close to zero two so
this is a nice trade to do the only
thing i am afraid of
is i apply here a small spread as you
can see i put two percent so this is
explaining why i have some difference
here of course it's more expensive if i
buy and cheaper if i sell because this
is how it happens in real life but i'm
afraid i didn't account for the real
spreads they're gonna be in this market
so i'm gonna check this at the open and
if the spreads are not too high i think
we're gonna get into that trade because
if it starts to move higher market
makers are gonna be in big big trouble
here because once again this is coming
from september guys so that they cannot
wait they need to buy shares right away
when it moves higher and as you can see
most of it
most of the position is coming from
september all right so
and we have the short term breakout so
it looks like you know it's worth a try
now let's have a look so and just to
conclude synthetic shot is 60 we can go
to 112. so what does it means it means
that 50
of the flowchair would need to be both
if all the options are in the money
of course this is happening only with a
very very high levels of spots
we need to go close to the 200 area so
we're not going to converge towards the
total synthetic shot but it's a good
indication of the gamma let's do the
same thing for bbig
bbig here you go same here we got into
this thread in our live trading
portfolio we got in uh here on the
retracement we bought at 660.
we were placed at 550 we didn't get
executed it was a pain here we didn't
take profits because it was looking like
the fifth wave might go higher but there
was a selling pressure and we got
stopped once again
very nicely in this fake out so you know
this is trading you know i've been doing
this long enough to know that this is
part of the game you know so each time
you're gonna have you're gonna use a
stop loss most of the time the trade
you're gonna do when your stop-loss is
triggered is gonna be a bad trade but
sometimes maybe one percent five percent
of the times is gonna just save your
entire portfolio so uh this is the only
way to make safe trades and here it's a
bit sad so we bought 660 we close uh 720
so we closed with some profits but
definitely it was not the best trade we
could do so we have time we're gonna do
more just very quickly an update of on
our live training portfolio we are not
having for now positive results we just
started last week august uh simulation
portfolio we were having very good
results now it's been one week for now
we have mitigated results but this is a
long term game and we have time we are
very confident that method would give us
good results if we wait a bit we're
going to keep applying the same method
and as usual it should finish in
positive territory so we will keep doing
this so this was just a quick update on
what we do on discord but here what is
the situation so one two okay this was
not easy to know if this is one two of
this is a one two and if this is the one
to hear the small one then i have a
fifth wave to come if not
then the five waves already happened as
you can see here if this starts here
okay so question we don't know and the
fifth could be here i mean this is a new
high so the the situation is very
difficult to analyze here
uh maybe there is one more wave for now
i see weakness i see a bearish
divergence macd going lower on the
hourly time frame when the market is
making new highs this is a fake out that
bulls actually failed to confirm as a
real breakout
so this is not good we have the
divergence on the hourly timeframe we
have it on the for us timeframe so we
have a double time frame divergence we
have potential five waves complete so
i'm not sure i wouldn't get in here for
sure because it's too high the only
positive thing as i said in the recap i
posted this morning in my discord is
that here we consolidate just below the
resistance level so it looks like you
know the bears are not able to take
ground so it's you know the only good
news i see here and i have a counting
where potentially we have a fifth wave
so it's really like for me a pure gamble
from here i don't have really bullish
signals i don't have bearish signals uh
if we apply the usual uh fib extension
method we come up with a target between
16 and 22 so somewhere here okay so if
we close above 11 30 on the daily then
probably this would happen but once
again we will not get back into this
trade it's a winner with small gain we
go to the next one and let's have a look
guys on the synthetic short interest so
very interesting for those who remember
you know i'm basically having all the
synthetic short interest that i keep
here each time i compute it and dbig you
can see we were at 66
total synthetic short in august then we
went to 95
and today we are back to 67 okay so let
me show you guys quickly and i'm gonna
tell you what this means but i can tell
you already this means that call options
uh holders are unwinding the positions
they're taking profits so this is
diminishing so this is not as bullish as
what i see on sprc where it's growing so
it looks like people sell bbig to go to
spr team so maybe this is the right move
i don't know and once again where is it
coming from same thing mostly september
here you check the big greens so
september and you don't have that many
upside calls here you know you don't
have open interest above 23 so that's
why maybe people go to sprt because they
want very out of the money strikes i
don't know but for this reason there is
less gamma as well only between 45 and
67 so 20 of gamma roughly the same
market cap slightly bigger so yeah this
is less interesting for me but once
again there might be a fifth wave here
too so the only thing i wanted to add
once again for those who really are
invested into anc gme and that are not
happy that i make this kind of videos i
just want to tell you again and i told
you before that i think that this is a
virtuous cycle because right now amc is
looking good maybe it's not skyrocketing
but those gains they are made you know
by whom by the same investors that go
into amc so if they make money here if
they squeeze some hedge funds on those
smaller place
this is money that can go to amc and gme
so i think that this is all going
together this is the same fight that's
what i wanted to tell you guys and i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're going
to be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore see
you guys